wie sieht so ein corona konformes
weihnachten aus gibt es das überhaupt
hilft vielleicht doch das mit der maske
das mit dem lüften mit dem abstand
halten sind corona tests vor dem feiern
eine gute idee das wollen wir heute
alles versuchen zu klären und zwar mit
zwei gesprächspartnern einmal in meinem
kollegen sven ricken der steht in
hamburg auf der reeperbahn und zwar in
einem etwas besonderen testzentrum dass
wir das gleich mal genau angucken und
später sprechen wir mit dem biologen aus
frankfurt martin stürmer der uns viele
fragen dazu beantworten wird aber erst
mal sage ich jetzt hallo sven hallo
hamburg neuen grüße nach mainz hallo ja
ich stehe auf dem spielbudenplatz direkt
gegenüber vom musical theater dass viele
natürlich kennen vom tina turner musical
und hinter mir wenn ich mal mit der
kamera über schwenke ist sicherlich
eines der ungewöhnlichsten testzentren
in deutschland das hier von den klub
betreibern oder von einem club betreiber
initiiert wurde weil die ursprungsidee
war zu sagen bevor man hier vielleicht
irgendwann doch wieder die clubs feiern
die clubs nutzen kann
macht man ein corona test und das war
die idee zu sagen man kann damit die
clubszene wieder ein bisschen beleben
und jetzt ist es tatsächlich europas
günstigste test den man hier machen kann
das ist ein pcr test also der der auch
einigermaßen sicher das ergebnis an
zeigt man kriegt hier keine
wattestäbchen in die nase gedrückt
sondern man darf hier wir gucken uns das
gleich mal an gurgeln und dann kriegt
man innerhalb maximal von 24 stunden ein
ergebnis und wie man sieht die schlange
tagsüber ist immer so lange es geht hier
wahnsinnig schnell weil man hier alles
online vorbestellt und alle
bestätigungen auch per sms und online
macht von daher bilden sich hier zwar
lange schlangen aber die werden auch
relativ schnell wieder abgearbeitet und
der das ganze initiiert hat der auch auf
die idee gekommen ist und der uns gleich
mal ein bisschen erzählen kann wie es
hier drin aussieht axel komm zu mir ist
axel strelitz wir drehen uns mal ein
bisschen hier in die scheinwerfer rein
axel man erst mal funktioniert ja sag
mal schnell was was war die idee zu
sagen wir müssen hier auf der reeperbahn
mitten in hamburg im testzentrum haben
warum habt ihr das gemacht
das waren mehrere schlaflose nicht
wirklich betrage im musikclub auch die
panik seinen werken museum und da sind
über 100 mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeiter stellen kann es sein dass
das mikrofon gerade gemietet ist wir
hören ihnen nicht getrieben und sorgen
bereitet ich selber muss ja auch von
irgendwas leben und ich habe googelt man
sich so durch die nacht und denkt man
muss doch mal waschen dann irgendwie mit
diesem virus aktuelle muss man eben kurz
gucken dass anscheinend das mikro zu
leise ist nächstes eigentlich nicht
gemietet
sonst muss ich vielleicht einen tick
lauter sprechen das kriegen wir hin
dann habe ich mir so gedacht man muss
doch wirklich jetzt mal ein weg finden
mit diesem scheiß virus zu leben da muss
es doch irgendwas gibt es kann doch
nicht sein dass das ganze leben
einfriert und da kamen eine person jonas
schmidt chanasit vom bernhard nocht
institut in einem interview hat
geschrieben auch wir müssen jetzt
anfangen virus klug umzugehen
ich habe den also angeschrieben das
beratungsinstitut ist so 200 meter von
hier entfernt und habe ihm einmal
erhöhte mitgeteilt und schrieb der mir
tatsächlich zurück und schrieb wer
strelitz habe das gelesen
lassen sie uns mal kaffee trinken ich
kann ihre sorgen verstehen und dann habe
ich ihm gesagt herr professor wenn ich
jetzt hier auf diesem spiel wurden platz
in die mitte der reeperbahn so container
stellen würde und die leute mit dem pc
erst testen würde
und die werden negativ wie lange bin ich
denn dann für andere nicht infektiös
oder dann gesagt das ist eine kluge
frage das können wir gerne mal
ausrechnen dass es eine ideologische
biologische frage und da sind wir zu dem
ergebnis gekommen bis 36 stunden das
beruht auf der annahme selbst werde ich
mich zwischenzeitlich infiziere muss das
virus ja erstmal sich replizieren also
vermehren im körper und dazu braucht es
ein paar tage und dann sagt 36 stunden
bin ich auf jeden fall so sicher dass
ich nicht genug virus virus im körper
haben andere zu infizieren und beruht
auf dieser annahme sagt dann lass uns
doch leute setzen und vielleicht ein
grünes bändchen um bin wenn die
negativserie war also der grundgedanke
schicken grüne welchen finde ich jetzt
bedenklich vielleicht geht das auch
anders und dann habe ich meinen besten
freund den heiko fuchs dazu geholt der
ist seit 20 jahren unternehmen oder
gehört ich finde dafür eine ablösung und
auch eine weblösung
dass wir man sieht ja hier auch die
schlangen sind kurz habe sehr enge tag
dass wir das alles digital abarbeiten
können und müssen wir drüber gehen jetzt
jetzt muss man sein kann ich nachweisen
dass die schlangen tagsüber ja ganz
schnell einen gefallen tun doch dann
anderes mikrofon noch mal checken weil
das kommt bei uns nicht an wir hören
quasi dein gesprächspartner nur über den
ton an dann einmal mainkofen man ja dazu
sagen dass ich alles alleine wir haben
kein kamerateam da das heißt er ist also
eine one-man-show da kann es schon mal
passieren dass sind seiner technik
patzer passiert funktioniert ist jetzt
das mikrofon testete bitte nochmal ja
ich mache das mikro jetzt einmal wie man
das in der technik also macht mit dem
reset einmal an und wieder aus und wir
gehen mal einmal ist formal in diese
richtung und ich hoffe dass man es jetzt
besser hören kann nicht immer ganz
verschwunden ich versuche das noch mal
ja ich bin dann bleibt er jetzt einfach
wir haben ja alle masken auf ein
bisschen dichter bei mir
axel erzähl mal als dann die idee kam
dass hier zu machen im moment seid ihr
was weihnachten betrifft glaube ich
ziemlich gut gebucht wie ausgebucht wir
haben jetzt auch die kapazitäten wochen
mal erhöht und werden auch morgen noch
einen weiteren container zum gurgeln
geliefert bekommen die unter aller
herrgottsfrühe um 7
dann werden wir noch einmal die
kapazitäten erhöhen wir haben kein
tolles labor das mit uns das schon seit
dem sommer abgestimmt hat denn das
besondere ist ja das gurgeln bei uns das
dürfen wir da eigentlich rein gehen
sonst stück ja wir sprechen ja also ich
drehe uns mal so rum dann sehen wir uns
wieder da ist marina und da sind wir
test habe ob der gültig ist es gibt ja
auch leute die ganz woanders gebucht
haben trotzdem hierherkommen und
das ist eigentlich auch alle stangen und
gehen hier den schlanken und darf
erhitzen werden die personaldaten einmal
abgeglichen
das heißt die meldedaten denn wir haben
hier eine infektionskrankheit die
meldepflicht ich gehe
wir wollen ja nicht jeden weg einzeln
zeigen dass wir sagen wir jetzt zum
thema weihnachten merkt er dass wir
stark wie können wir in die richtung
gehen dass wir kurzem habt das finde ich
gut
da komm ich geb dir das in die hand und
fällt es dir einfach mal raus aus dem
clips aktionsjahr
veranstaltungstechniker der kann das
kann es auch direkt rausnehmen aus dem
kreis noch okay dann bleibe ich bei ihm
geht leider nicht axel du musst über
mich sprechen das macht nichts das sieht
schick aus ich nehme es dir wieder ab
und so spricht einfach über mich ein
bisschen lauter so wir sind jetzt hier
in einem dieser container in denen die
veranstaltungen stattfinden hier wird
jetzt gerade mal sind wir kurz warten
weil hier wird jetzt gerade tatsächlich
gewirbelt und die dame haben natürlich
vorher nicht informiert kurz wir
sprachen über weihnachten das merkt ihr
schon oder das jetzt hier viel mehr los
ist
dann kannst du mal ein licht aufgehen
anfragen entgegen halten weil das ist
echt schwierig ihn zu verstehen mit der
maske ich ziehe jetzt mal an meinem
anstieg mikrofon und haltet ihr das ein
bisschen so heesen will das gurgel
also das ist romane die sitzen einer
druckkabine das heißt da können keine
erosion reinkommt ist aber deswegen auch
kein medizinisches personal roman als
künstlerin als eine eine kleidung die
seite rinnen und dj hier auf der
reeperbahn und das heißt ihr beschäftigt
hier diejenigen die im moment unter
corona auf künstlerischer seite am
stärksten leiden das ist genau richtig
als sie haben eine ganze familie romane
ist er ihr mann ist auch künstler und
auch dieter hier auf der reeperbahn und
der sohn sitzt eine kabine weiter
medizinstudent hat sein abitur gemacht
also der dreiköpfige familie die jetzt
arbeit gefunden hat scheint jetzt auch
ein produktionsleiter von schmidt
theater und restaurantschiff leiterin
haben wir hier auch die hier jetzt weil
wir durch die kurzarbeit verliert macht
einfach weniger geld und die leute sind
ganz froh wieder in arbeit und brot zu
kommen das ist so eine initiative die
gibt's eigentlich nur noch st pauli das
ist das ist auch witzig alle leute sagen
das ist halt das irgendwie nach hause
kommen gerade da heißt die eltern das
gefühl guck mal achtung ist ja auch hier
wie schön und gut dass wir das wieder
was tun können das ist eigentlich ganz
schönes gefühl das machen wir jetzt noch
den kleinen blick in die google kamera
wie das funktioniert hat dürfen wir das
selbst so für uns kleinen kurbel becher
man muss dazu sagen diejenigen zu denen
wir jetzt hierher kommen die wussten gar
nicht dass wir so weit kommen weil wir
eigentlich weiter vorne bleiben wollten
deswegen versuchen wir das jetzt einfach
mal ich halte das denke ich soll burgen
okay ich gebe dir mal die kamera in die
hand
ich muss dazu sagen dass ich es vorher
noch nicht probiert habe und auch
bislang noch nicht so wie du glaube ich
das glück hatte vier milliliter kochsalz
was macht also aufdrehen eigentlich kann
man mit dem mikro etwas dichter und
maler was muss ich tun
ja so einfach googlen reinnehmen und
gurgeln komm runter mit dem zeug sind
sehr elegant wir haben das nicht
gebracht das habt ihr glaube ich gemerkt
aber auch zuhause ablegen geräten oder
unterwegs
es schmeckt er schmeckt ein bisschen
salzig muss man dazu sagen nicht so wie
eine bio marisk uhr an der ost- oder
nordsee dazu es ist deutlich
der gesamt geschmacksrichtung besonders
ist deutlich angenehmer als wenn man so
ein langes stäbchen in die nase bekommt
das auch schon ein paar mal erleben
helfen kann ich sagen und kesseln und
jetzt das ergebnis ich nehme jetzt mal
erstmalig wird man sagen ich glaube wir
haben uns einen eindruck verschaffen den
derzeit ein bisschen weiter drüber du
hast auf jeden fall ja das war der
kleine eindruck ja das war auf jeden
fall der erste live kochen hat selbst im
internet nicht gesehen habe
vielen dank erstmal gucken ob es nachher
noch jemand findet der tatsächlichen
test macht für die feiertage und
vielleicht fliegt oder mikrofonen ja
auch noch zum laufen dass er auch super
vielen dank erstmal nach hamburg wir
sind gleich nochmal hier genau wir
gucken gleich noch mal zu euch
tatsächlich aber müssen wir ja
feststellen dass die frage ist ob so ein
text überhaupt wirklich sinnvoll ist
oder ob es nicht vielleicht doch besser
wäre auch bestimmte sachen zu verzichten
zum beispiel zu viele menschen zu
treffen und heute gab es mal wieder eine
pressekonferenz des robert koch
instituts und der rk ii chef herr wieler
hat dort eindringlich darum gebeten dass
man die kontakte über die
weihnachtsfeiertage so gering wie
möglich
das hat er gesagt ich bitte sie heute
eindringlich darum die tage zwischen den
jahren in ruhe und wirklich nur im
kleinsten familienkreis zu verbringen
bitte schenken sie ihre kontakte auf das
nötigste ein verreisen sie nicht treffen
sie möglichst nur wenige und wenn dann
nur immer dieselben menschen
ja das klingt fast ein bisschen so wie
lassen sie bitte weihnachten ausfallen
was sagt denn unser stamm virologe dazu
martin stürmer aus frankfurt einen
schönen guten abend heute mal beim
anderen setting im hintergrund sonst
nicht mehr im wohnzimmer heute ja genau
tatsächlich ist ein neues skype zimmer
fertig geworden wo ich ein bisschen
ungestörter sein kann um die familie
musste nicht darunter leiden wenn ich
das ganze zeit das wohnzimmer blockiere
der müssen die immer nach oben
verschwinden jetzt aber mal getauscht
ich denke das ist auch ein ganz netter
hintergrund macht ja stichwort familie
was herr wieder heute gesagt klingt ja
tatsächlich ein bisschen die lassen sie
weihnachten lieber ausfallen oder ja so
ein bisschen dabei es ist tatsächlich so
ich hab mal ganz interessante
modellrechnung gesehen und da ist es so
dass werden wir unser ehrgeiziges ziel
wirklich erreichen wollen januar die
zahlen deutlich nach unten zu bekommen
dann dürfen wir weihnachten wirklich nur
ganz marginal diese freiheiten ausnutzen
sondern sollten uns wirklich mehr oder
weniger alle zurücknehmen und wirklich
im kleinsten kreise feiern
dann haben wir die chance dieses ziel zu
erreichen sobald wir über über 50
prozent der bevölkerung die freiheiten
voll ausnutzt wird uns dieses ziele
mitte januar nicht gelingen wie feiern
sie dann persönlich was haben sie sich
überlegt ja wir sind eine kleine familie
wir sind zu dritt
wir werden auch zutritt bleiben ist auf
ein tag da wird meine tochter aus erster
ehe kommen so besucht er war also gerade
mal vier leute an einem tag
und das war es dann schon es gibt ja
doch haben sie da schon gesagt relativ
klare regeln aber die man nicht
unbedingt ausnutzen sollte bisschen
kompliziert wird es dadurch dass jedes
bundesland nach einer eigenen regeln
aufgestellt hat mein kollege an seinen
stern hat man versucht das kurz für uns
zusammen zu fassen
weihnachten in deutschland in diesem
jahr vor allem auch bestimmt von
antivirus regeln
die können unterschiedlich sein je nach
bundesland grundsätzlich aber gilt das
vom 24
bis 26 dezember darf ein haushalt vier
weitere personen aus dem engsten
familienkreis einladen plus kinder bis
14 jahre
wie viele haushalte dadurch
zusammenkommen spielt keine rolle
zum engsten familienkreis zählen etwa
großeltern eltern kinder geschwister ehe
und lebenspartner an silvester gibt es
keine lockerungen keine ausnahmen
es gelten dann wie bislang die aktuell
strengen kontakt beschränkungen maximal
fünf personen aus zwei haushalten
dürften sich treffen
der verkauf von böllern und pyrotechnik
wurde verboten
auch der jahreswechsel in diesem jahr
also bestimmt von antivirus regeln
daher stelle mario luge in frankfurt
leiter eines labors dort was ist denn
jetzt ihr rad wie kann sicheres feiern
gelingen oder ist das eigentlich schon
paradox an sich
nein es ist kann schon gelegen wir haben
jetzt ein baustein an möglichen baustein
gesehen
der test vor den feiertagen da wenn man
sicherlich noch etwas intensiver darüber
diskutieren aber es gilt im prinzip für
das verhalten an weihnachten das gleiche
wie im alltag wenn man die a-ha regeln
plus lüften konsequent anwendet also
möglichst auf abstand bleibt soweit es
eben geht die antigene nicht außer acht
lässt wann auch immer die alltags maske
trägt und häufig lüftet oder ein teil
eben auch draußen verbringen schön lange
spaziergang zb zu machen
auch dann ist es durchaus möglich ein
relativ sicheres weihnachten zu
verbringen wenn wirklich vielleicht den
den älteren unter den feiernden der ft2
maske angedeihen zu lassen und auf die
umarmung zu verzichten auch das küsschen
dann hat man schon viel gewonnen und
abgesehen davon wenn man wie gesagt
reduziert auf das minimum
dann ist das so eigentlich deutlich
besser also statt bescherung unterm baum
im handel eigentlichen heimeligen
wohnzimmer den spaziergang den man sonst
immer zu ostern macht und dann
vielleicht die geschicke im wald
verstecken
sie hat schon gesagt dieser test haben
wir gerade gesehen beim kollegen sven
ricken in hamburg ist das tatsächlich
was was sie jetzt empfehlen würden damit
man zumindest eine kleine sicherheit hat
und wenn ja wann sollte man den machen
um dann auch zu wissen okay jetzt kann
ich jemanden treffen
es gibt ja verschiedene möglichkeiten
die man tests in eine strategie
beendet so manch einer wird vielleicht
gerade aktuell so eine kleine vor
quarantäne machen sprich die familie die
kinder rausnehmen aus dem alltag ein
bisschen unter sich bleiben um kontakte
zu reduzieren dann kann man so eine
quarantäne mit einem test abschließen
und kann dann relativ sicher sein dass
man die weihnachtsfeiertage niemanden
ansteckt wenn ich jetzt keine solche
quarantäne machen kann oder machen will
dann ist der pcr test sicherlich die
bessere option im vergleich zum anti gen
test weil einfach das fenster für die
sicherheit bei der pca höher ist als
beim anti gen test und natürlich ist es
besser je näher man an den zeitpunkt
daran geht weil man geben tatsächlich
zum beispiel die großeltern besuchen
geht stellen weil ich muss noch mal ganz
kurz unsere kommentare gucken wie ich es
immer mal wieder mache und tatsächlich
hier mal kurz zur saison aufrufen denn
auf facebook merke ich geht es doch
gerade echt ein bisschen unangenehm ab
also es wäre schön wenn ihr und sie euch
da an eine seriöse und vor allem
freundliche diskussions kultur halten
würde weil sich gegenseitig zu
beschimpfen das bringt hier niemandem
was und ist vor allem relativ und
weihnachtlich würde ich sagen so also
tatsächlich ein test wäre eine
möglichkeit aber ist ja auch ein
bisschen das risiko dass man dann denkt
juhu ich kann alles machen ich bin safe
oder genau das darf man definitiv nicht
machen also selbst wenn der test jetzt
negativ ist gelten die optimalen
verhaltensregeln wie sie genannt habe
natürlich weiterhin
mir ist natürlich auch klar wenn man
beim essen zusammen sitzt kann man die
maske nicht tragen
es ist völlig logisch es geht ja auch
darum ein maximum an möglicher
sicherheit zu gewinnen
und der text trägt sicherlich dazu bei
wenn man kurzfristig machen kann
aber er darf nicht die alleinige
sicherheit darstellen weil dann wird man
sich in einer falschen sicherheit und
ich glaube keiner von uns möchte daher
verantwortlich sein
meine großeltern sich anstecken und
möglicherweise schwer erkranken so ich
habe ja ein paar fragen
mal wieder zum test tatsächlich da gab
es ja mal diesen etwas merkwürdigen
versuch mit cola wo versucht wurde
nachzuweisen dass diese tests nichts
tauchen gerade die schnelltests weil sie
bei cola anschlagen würden hat hier
kriegs fisch auf youtube auch gefragt
ist es so sind die tests so
unzuverlässig was hat es mit dieser
coole sache auf sich
nicola ist eine säure und wenn ich eine
säure und gepuffert auf einem test kippe
dann geht halt das kaputt was dahin drin
dafür sorgt dass das signal richtig
detektiert wird dann ich meine nicht
umsonst sind bei solchen tests eine
packungsbeilage mit dabei wie man einen
solchen test durchzuführen hat und
sollte ich jetzt tatsächlich ordentlich
cola getrunken haben und mache dann ein
abstrich dann geht dieser abstrich
trotzdem in eine sogenannte puffer
lösung der die säure die die säure
neutralisiert und ich sagen cola macht
das ding einfach kaputt genau es ist
eine völlig invalide durchführung des
tests sind somit gesagt dieses ganze
experiment überhaupt nichts aus über die
qualität eines testes außer dass
kohlensäure ist und vielleicht nichts
über maß getrunken werden sollte
hier wurde noch mal gerade eine vater
gestellt zu dem test denen der kollege
ist wenn regen gerade in hamburg gemacht
hat nämlich warum denn eigentlich
gurgeln was ist denn das von der test
positiv noch nicht so richtig weit
verbreitet es stimmt es verbreitet sich
immer mehr wir haben auch jemanden zur
kooperationspartner der stadt dem
abstrich auch eine grobe lösung anbietet
ich war sehr skeptisch am anfang weil
ich mir gedacht hat boa man googelt da
ordentlich mit ordentlich viel lösungen
und nehme davon nur ein bruchteil für
die folgende untersuchung habe den test
aber selber durchgeführt wir haben so
eine interne kontrolle mit drin
die uns zeigt er auch wirklich
menschliche zellen mit in diesem dieser
flüssigkeit drin sind und das hat
erstaunlich gut funktioniert und gerade
wenn man diese taste zum beispiel auch
zu hause machen möchte also spricht
nicht die pc untersuchung aber die pro
mitnahme dann ist so eine gurgellösung
sicherlich deutlich einfacher zu machen
als sich mit einem abstrich kupfer in
der nase oder im rachen umzupolen
so die frage ist ja doch trotzdem die
sich friede userinnen und user und viele
menschen draußen stellen wie
feiere ich denn jetzt eigentlich und was
ist tatsächlich wie gefährlich ich würde
ganz gerne etwas zeigen was wir hier
vorbereitet haben nämlich das muss ich
noch mal ein tablet hier in betrieb
nehmen einmal auf unseren rechner
daneben miersch alten liebe regie also
auf denen da genau da gibt es nämlich
bei uns auf der zdf heute gibt es eine
sogenannte scroll story haben wir das
genannt da kann man sich nämlich durch
scrollen passend fürs handy und dort
haben wir mal genau versucht zu zeigen
ob masken zum beispiel helfen beim
feiern so und da ist dann die frage wie
kann das ganze funktionieren man kann
sich das so durch scrollt also da wird
zum beispiel gesagt wenn du drei stunden
gefeiert und gelüftet wird und
zusätzlich alle dauerhaft alltags masken
tragen
sinkt die individuelle ansteckungsgefahr
auf unter drei prozent dass sich
mindestens eine weitere person an steckt
kann mit einer wahrscheinlichkeit von 20
prozent aber immer noch nicht
ausgeschlossen werden also da kann man
sehr schön sehen hier in dieser scroll
story wie die verschiedenen sachen
wirken zum beispiel dann kann man das
schweizer käse modell mal ausprobieren
also tatsächlich alle regeln dies so
geht ein halten abstand masken tragen
lüften aber auch dass mit dem lüften ist
wenn man weiter hoch scrollt nicht immer
unproblematisch denn einfach nur das
fenster zu kippen reicht nicht
stattdessen sollte man stoßlüften und
dann kann man sehen dass sich dadurch in
dieser story kann man das sehr schön
sehen das risiko minimiert den link
packen wir euch gleich in die kommentare
und in den chat damit ihr euch das mal
in ruhe angucken könnt aber das ist
tatsächlich jedoch ein bisschen komische
vorstellung der stürmende wenn man sitzt
im wohnzimmer vielleicht zu fünft sechst
alle tragen masken und das fenster
sperrangelweit auf richtig weihnachtlich
wird es dann nicht oder nein das ist
wohl wahr und da und ich muss das hier
für sich individuell entscheiden wo er
oder sie das risiko eher hinlegt und das
ist etwas was niemand vorschreiben kann
mit sprechen ja auch nur empfehlungen
aus und wenn es darum geht wie ich am
sichersten verfahren kann ist es eben
die kombination aus all dem was wir bis
dato besprochen haben und obliegt es wie
gesagt jedem
selber wie oder was man macht ich vor
meiner sicht aus das jahr ist insgesamt
von vielen dingen geprägt die wir nicht
machen konnten auch wenn wir sie gerne
gemacht hätten das betrifft biologen
genauso wie ihnen dann auch und deswegen
bin ich jetzt auch der meinung ist macht
man den haken dran
auch silvester wird nicht so sein wie
wir es kennen das wird wahrscheinlich
sehr leise werden und das ist einfach
ein verrücktes jahr und wenn wir uns da
arbeite ich alle zusammenreißen und das
als gesellschaftliches problem sehen was
wir nur gemeinsam lösen können weil man
eine gute chance dass wir zumindest im
neuen jahr dass wir das nicht ganz so
heftig beginnen müssen wie das alte
aufgehört hat so ich habe noch ein paar
fragen an sie die würde ich sagen
beantworten weg leicht denn mein kollege
ist wenn regen ist noch mal in hamburg
und ich glaube die man gefunden mit dem
wir noch mal sprechen können tatsächlich
über die frage testen jetzt sich frei
testen quasi um das weihnachten doch
noch mal zusammen zu erleben was hast du
denn da getroffen werden tatsächlich
waren wie heute vormittag schon einmal
hier und haben mit vielen gesprochen die
genau aus diesem grund diesen test hier
gewählt haben weil sie sagen oma und opa
kommen zu besuch oder sie selber reisen
zu der verwandtschaft und ist total
liebt es zu stehen geblieben bist ich
frage das hier jetzt auch mal kurz rein
wenn ich das richtig verstanden hat bei
euch spielt auch die frage weihnachten
eine rolle für die familie einfach das
sicherste gefühl wenn man möchte daher
einfach vorsichtiger sein und lieber
einmal zu viel als einmal zu wenig um
einfach alle gesund durch sehr zu
bekommen ja und man stellt irgendwie
fest es gibt auch leider immer noch um
vernünftige leute weil es ja eigentlich
relativ leicht das kannst du das so
nachvollziehen gar nicht ich finde das
sehr unverantwortlich und man sollte auf
jeden fall auf seine mitmenschen achten
also rücksicht nehmen und achtsam sein
und generell einfach den menschen den
respekt entgegenbringen der mann selber
entgegengebracht haben möchte und nicht
andere menschen in gefahr bringen und
hast du den test hier schon mal gemacht
schon mal gegoogelt noch nicht gewirbelt
ich kann dir aus eigener erfahrung von
eben sagen es schmeckt ganz lecker ist
alles soll dann freue ich mich ja wenn
maximal fragen diesen feiern wird alles
gute für weihnachten
feiert ihr herrlich hier oder wo feiert
ihr die eltern die großeltern kommen
sagt sie gerade zu besuch und das war
wie gesagt auch das stimmungsbild was
wir heute morgen hier schon eingesammelt
haben dass relativ viele diese
möglichkeit hier nutzen weil es eben
auch sehr zentral liegt und weil es
durch die app gesteuerte anmeldung hier
relativ zügig geht und weil
wahrscheinlich auch relativ viele sagen
so ein stäbchen der nase ist natürlich
sicher und gut aber auch sehr unangenehm
und wir haben ja auch gerade eben gehört
die gurgel lösung ist auch sehr sicher
und das ergebnis hier kommt auch maximal
innerhalb von 20 stunden und dann hat
man zumindest für diese 36 stunden die
achsel vorhin erzählt hat eine
gewissheit und ja dafür dass zentral
licht und hier gut angesteuert werden
kann
heute morgen war es voller wenn ich
jetzt hier einmal so rum gucke bin ich
hier jetzt relativ alleine für
ungewohntes bild von hamburgern auf der
bahn ja vor allem um diese uhrzeit aber
letztlich das hat aktuell ja auch
erzählt hier die clubszene und alles um
uns herum hat natürlich geschlossen
der einzige der noch offen hat ist der
kleine kinos da drüben dann die
restlichen dinge des täglichen lebens
verkauft aber natürlich wie sich das für
die reeperbahn gehört nur nicht
alkoholische getränke so also wir wissen
oder du weißt dann hoffentlich morgen ob
du negativ bist was du dir alle wünschen
und dann hast du zumindest für
anderthalb tage ein bisschen ruhe sven
vielen dank für diese eindrücke aus
hamburg und dann gehen wir doch mal
rüber so martin stürmer in frankfurt
weil ich habe hier noch ein paar fragen
also einmal noch mal zu dieser gurgel
testlösung was halten sie davon möchte
ulrich neumann wissen ist dass
tatsächlich ein eine gute lösung und ist
genauso sicher und und bringt die
gleichen ergebnisse wie die stäbchen
ja das ist tatsächlich unserer erfahrung
das ist eine gute alternative lösung ist
und tatsächlich adäquat er zu den
stäbchen zu werten ist
und dann geht es hier eine frage zu den
ja selbst heißt dies ergibt die
schnelltests da müssen wir einmal darauf
hinweisen dass es im kölner raum eine
firma gab die hat solche tests angeboten
die wurden in ganz deutschland verkauft
und die sind jetzt werden alle
zurückgerufen weil
tatsächlich auch der einfache verkauf
von solchen corona selbsttests nicht
legal ist das darf eigentlich das dürfen
nur apotheken abgeben und dort dürfen
sie nicht abgeben wenn sie dürfen das
selber durchführen
das muss durch medizinisches
fachpersonal gemacht werden das heißt
von diesem corona selbst fest sollte man
dringend die finger lassen oder stürmer
absolut alles was da so im internet für
den privatgebrauch angeboten wird finger
weg weil es ist nicht zugelassen und das
ergebnis kann ich überprüft werden ich
kann für die garantie für die für die
das ergebnis überhaupt nicht garantieren
und warum machen wir den test warum
geben wir das geld aus weil wir uns ein
gewisses stück sicherheit damit beginnen
möchten und nichts wäre schlimmer als
durch einen solchen test ein falsch
negatives ergebnis zu bekommen und seine
liebsten anzustecken das sollte man
wirklich nicht machen so es mich mal in
die kommentare schauen gibt es einen
schönen auf facebook von camille meint
du meine güte feiert doch einfach in
aller stille ohne großen rummel
stimmt doch jeder wenn die bucklige
verwandtschaft an rollt also für alle
die keine lust haben wir zum zu vielen
leuten die man sonst im jahr nicht sie
zu feiern und sich merkwürdig an zu
schweigen er ist wahrscheinlich das
beste weihnachten überhaupt wenn man
eine gute ausrede hat eva schreibt hier
auf youtube für feiern weihnachten
kleinen kreis nächstes jahr dann so
hoffe ich mit unseren kindern und enkeln
ein schneller test wäre interessant aber
hört an unserer planung jetzt nichts
ändern und gibt es noch eine frage von
sam winchester auf youtube junge leute
dürfen nicht untereinander feiern aber
zu weihnachten oma und opa ansteckend
ist okay fragezeichen das würde ich mal
eigentlich mit einem deutlichen nein
beantworten oder stürmer ja natürlich
das ist ja die die kritik auch gewesen
gerade an dem ersten entwurf wo wir
jetzt sind ein total lockdown begeben
dürfen und zweite zwei auszeiten maximal
treffen uns wird sich sollte zu
weihnachten dem ganzen tür und tor
geöffnet werden alle generationen
zusammen
am besten jeden tag zehn neue leute
einladen
also ich bin heilfroh dass es wenigstens
auf ein deutliches maß reduziert worden
ist
aber ich kann dem nur zustimmen ich kann
nur empfehlen die gleichen maßstäbe im
augenblick anzulegen
die man das ganze jahr macht oder die
ganze zeit jetzt macht weniger ist
tatsächlich dieses jahr komplett mehr
das heißt auch wenn man jetzt überlegt
man staffelt das ganze man trifft zu
weihnachten vielleicht sonst 20 leute
und jetzt macht man da kleine portion
sketchen draußen trifft über die drei
teile die 20 leute immer so in
anderthalb stunden slots ist das eine
gute idee
ja das ist natürlich auch wieder eine
durchmischung lage gibt es her also die
verordnung die erlaubt einem das aber
das ist natürlich trotzdem reisen denn
viele menschen durch die gegner hat
wechselnde kontakte und natürlich ist es
die engste familie aber wir können uns
doch auch bei diesem virus gerade nicht
sicher sein ob nicht auch unser bruder
unsere schwester dieses virus bekommen
oder bekommen haben weil das macht das
virus macht keine gefangenen es ist
wirklich jeder kleinste fehler wird
ausgenutzt das virus kann sich sehr
effektiv auch verbreiten und ich kann es
auf die schnelle niemandem ansehen ob er
oder sie das virus hat also ich würde
auch von diesen durch mischungen
definitiv abraten wenn es geht also hier
gibt's einen kommentar von florian ahler
auf youtube mal kurz mal zeigen bei mir
auf dem rechner
der ist nicht amüsiert herr meint
wunschträume die sich nicht erfüllen
lassen wenn schon das umfeld mit
völliger gleichgültigkeit ein
kaffeekränzchen nach dem anderen ab hält
bin stinksauer
so wird das nix also die frage ist jetzt
tatsächlich wann wissen wir hersteller
ob weihnachten das nächste super
spreading event gewesen ist oder ob es
doch irgendwie glimpflich abgelaufen ist
na gut da hilft uns prinzip die ganz
klassische anderthalb wochen regel das
haben wir jetzt überlegen dass das was
wir jetzt heute eine infektionszahlen
sehen nicht ungefähr drei wochen zurück
dann können wir halt hochrechnen und
sagen am 26 ist der letzte tag wo ich
wieder darf und dann gehen wir halt eben
kurz ins neue jahr ein und ab da werden
wir sehen wie es weitergeht und wir
sollten wir jetzt gegen ende der
weihnachtsfeiertage erstmal absinken
sehen
das dadurch dass der deutlich härtere
locker und jetzt eben greift und wenn
das ganze in die hose gegangen ist dann
steigen anfang januar die zahlen wieder
gut dann hoffen wir dass es nicht so
kommt dass die meisten menschen sich
vernünftig verhalten und möglichst keine
oder wenig kontakte haben hersteller
vielen dank dass ihr uns wieder rede und
antwort gestanden haben vielen dank fürs
zuschauen
schade das ist mal wieder ein bisschen
erst gar nicht erst in den kommentaren
aber ich bin sicher das wird sich
irgendwann vielleicht doch noch mal
einen denken dass man miteinander
ordentlich diskutiert für heute machen
wir den sack aber zu ich sage vielen
dank fürs zuschauen bis zum nächsten mal
macht gut und tschüss